what i want to do in this video is
familiarize ourselves with one of the
most important molecules in biology and
that is glucose sometimes referred to as
dextrose and the term dextrose comes
from the fact that the form of glucose
typically for typically found in nature
if you form a solution of it it's going
to polarize light to the right and
dexter in greek means right but the more
typical term glucose this literally
means sweet in greek if you ask a greek
friend to say sweet it sounds like lucos
or i'm not saying it perfectly but it
sounds a lot like a glucose and that's
because that's where the word comes from
and it is super important because it is
it is it is how energy is stored and
transferred in biological systems in
fact right now when if someone were to
talk about your blood your blood sugar
they're talking about the glucose
content
so when people talk about blood
blood sugar they're talking about your
they're talking about your glucose
content the whole process of
photosynthesis this is all about plants
using harnessing the sun's energy and
storing that energy in the form of
glucose when we talk about when we talk
about things like respiration in our in
our cells cellular respiration that's
all about taking glucose and using it to
fo and to to create atps which are the
molecular currency of energy inside of
our bodies so these are incred this is
an incredibly important molecule
we can start making chains of glucose to
form glycogen to form starches this
along with another similar another
simple sugar fructose you can use to
form our table sugar but even glucose by
itself is sweet so let's get familiar
with it as a molecule
so immediately when you look at this is
it kind of drawn as a as an open chain
we see that we have one two three
actually let me number these we have one
two
three
four five six carbons so
chemical formula would be c sub six a
subscript of six
we have how many hydrogens how many
hydrogens we have we have one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve hydrogens c6h12
and then we have how many oxygens do we
have we have one two three four five six
oxygens
six oxygens so you might notice we have
six carbons and then the ratio of for
every one oxygen we have two hydrogens
which is really the ratio of hydrogens
to oxygens in water and if we want to
really if we really want to if we uh and
obviously here we don't have just two
hydrogens and one oxygen we have 12
hydrogens and six oxygens but it's
really good to even just familiarize
yourself with what are the different
parts here so we see on the number one
carbon
it is part of a carbonyl group
when a carbon is bonded
to double bonded to an oxygen like that
that's a carbonyl
carbonyl
carbonyl group and in fact because this
carbon it's double bonded to an oxygen
but then its other bonds are two uh i
guess you could say a a
carbon chain right over here and then
but this other bond right here is a
hydrogen we would call this an aldehyde
we would call this
an aldehyde group and it makes
aldehyde
and it would officially make the entire
molecule an aldehyde if you contain an
aldehyde group you are an aldehyde so
glucose and when it's written when it's
drawn as a straight chain or it's in a
straight chain form it would be
considered an aldehyde and then of
course it has all these hydroxyl groups
on them and these hydroxyl groups these
oh groups over here that would
officially make glucose also it would
officially make it an alcohol and it's
neat to to keep in mind how the
structure is so you have six carbons
one of them is part of this aldehyde
group it's it's part of this carbonyl
right over here and then the other five
are each bonded to a hydroxyl and when
i've oriented it this way
four of the hydroxyls are on the right
hand side and the one on the three
carbon is on the left hand side and all
of the other carbon bonds are with
hydrogen carbon likes to form four
covalent bonds every one of these six
carbons has formed four covalent bonds
and so you would fill up all the rest
once you've accounted for this carbonyl
here and you've accounted for all of
these hydroxyls everything else is going
to be a hydrogen
now this is when you've drawn when
you've drawn glucose just as a straight
chain but many times you will see it in
its cyclical form it's neat to kind of
think about how do you go from this form
to this form over here and so what i've
drawn here is this exact same this exact
open chain but i've started to i've
started to bend it a little bit and just
to be able to keep track of things let's
renumber the carbons so this is the
carbon that's part of the carbonyl group
so it's carbon one and then we number up
from there two
three
four
five and then that is the number six
carbon the reason why i've made these
this bond over here nice and fat is to
show that it's it's kind of closer to us
it's popping out of the page and as we
go from the the second carbon to the
first carbon we're going back into the
page we'll go from the third carbon to
the fourth carbon we are going we are
going back into the page right over here
so this big fat bond
this is
between carbon 3 and carbon 2 that's
this
that's this right over here and this
going from 2 to 1 that's this bond and
i'll draw it a little bit kind of going
in and then this bond is this bond right
over here and so take a second pause the
video if you need but try to orient
yourself to orient yourself imagine
we're going to take this to the right
like this to bring it over here and then
we're going to rotate
we're going to rotate this end and bend
it up backwards like that to get to this
form c6 is now bent all the way up is
now rotated all the way up there we've
bent we've bent this chain and the whole
reason is is because this will typically
react the hydroxyl group this is it this
is the the most typical form of glucose
you will see when you see in a sickle
form there's actually other forms that
you can have but the oxygen that forms a
hydroxyl group on the fifth carbon
it can it can attack it can attack the
the the number one carbon that forms
this carbonyl group and that's because
oxygen we've talked a lot about it is
very electronegative likes to hog
electrons so this carbon is partially
positive
and so you could take one of the lone
pairs
you could take one of so this oxygen
right over here it's going to have two
lone pairs let me just draw them as
neatly as i can that's one lone pair and
then this is another lone pair right
over here so this oxygen
can
form a bond with this carbon when we
learn organic chemistry in more depth
we'd call that a nucleophilic attack it
sounds very fancy but it's just the fact
that these are drawn to each other this
has a partially positive charge this guy
has a
lone pairs of electrons that can be used
to form bonds with things and so when
that when those electrons form this bond
or or bond to this carbon that's going
to be this bond
this bond
right over here and then this carbon can
let go
this carbon can let go of the electrons
in one of these let me do some more
obvious color
and in the double bond right over here
it could let go of one of the bonds the
electrons in one of the bonds and then
that can be taken back
by the oxygen or even better that can be
used by that oxygen to capture a
hydrogen proton in the solution actually
probably part of a
hydronium molecule but let me just draw
it this way
this would just be used to capture a
hydrogen proton that would just be a
hydrogen a hydrogen atom without its
electron it's just a hydrogen ion it
would just be a hydrogen proton and that
would form
this bond that would form this bond
right over here and let me let me just
be very clear this carbon this carbon
right over here is this carbon right
over there
this oxygen
this oxygen
is this oxygen
is that oxygen right over there and so
hopefully you see how it forms a cycle
and you're probably saying oh wait wait
aren't don't we have a little hydrogen
attached here isn't the way i've drawn
it looks like there's an extra hydrogen
over here and then that would leave this
guy with a positive charge you leave it
the positive charge but you can imagine
we're in a solution of water that hey i
have some i have another water molecule
right over here
and you know these things are all
bouncing around and interacting in
different ways but it can use let me do
that in the right color it could use
so that's oxygen it could use one of its
lone pairs instead of this you know this
will become positive temporarily but
then it can use it can do it can use one
of its lone pairs to grab just the
hydrogen proton which would allow which
will allow this character to take its to
take its electrons to take these
electrons back and turn into this
character and just be neutral and then
this this guy would have gained so we
have a a proton going into the solution
you have hydronium but we took a proton
from the solution we took a proton we
gave a proton to the solution and so you
could end up with this so the whole
reason i did this is just so when you
see it in biology class or chemistry
class you're not intimidated by in fact
this is something that's really valuable
to get very very familiar with because
you're going to see glucose and other
sugars in many many many different
molecules throughout your academic
career